[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 78
weekend votre émission dédiée à vos
sorties et loisirs aujourd'hui nous nous
intéresserons principalement à vos
rendez-vous du 7e et 8e art notamment
avec le festif photo qui s'ouvre à
rambouiller du 2 au 4 octobre et nous
parlerons du concert bratch dimanche 27
septembre à 17h30 à la Grange du Mané de
Montini le Bretonneux concert bénévole
pour récolter des fonds pour
l'association Solidarité nouvelle pour
le logement sur saintquanttin en Yveline
et maintenant place à nos premiers
invités Jean-Philippe gibbaud secrétaire
du Festiv photo de la forêt de
Rambouillet organisation bonjour bonjour
et Claude chose président de l'UR16
union régional des photographes
d'île-de-fance fédération qui participe
également au festif photo de Rambouillet
bonjour bonjour donc le festive photo se
déroule nous le disions sur embouillé du
2 au 4 octobre Jean-Philippe
présentez-nous ce ce festival alors
c'est un festival de photographie
animalière et de nature de paysage qui
se déroule principalement à la Bergerie
Nationale à la salle patenôre à
rambbouillet et à la sous-préfecture de
rambbouillet qui regroupera une
quarantaine d'expositions donc
différents lieux vous les avez cité la
bergerie la sous-préfecture le château
différentes expositions les expositions
qui ont déjà démarré pour certaines
alors certaines on a déjà installé des
expositions extérieures par exemple on a
une une exposition de la LPO et de terre
sauvage qui est à l'extérieur sur la
place de la mairie on a également
installé déjà le best of le résultat du
concours parce que tous les ans à
l'occasion du Festif photo on fait un
concours régional et donc cette
exposition est déjà installé dans la
cour royale la Bergerie Nationale je
crois que vous avez un invité d'honneur
un peu spécial ainsi qu'un Parin
pourriez-vous nous les présenter alors
on a effectivement un invité d'honneur
particulièrement prestigieux puisqu'il
s'agit de Ann Sylvester qui est un
militant pour l'environnement ah oui oui
un très grand militant
écologique qui qui a fait des photos
dans le monde
entier grand reporteur qui fait en ce
moment sur
l'Éthiopie un reportage sur sur les
femmes d'Éthiopie le peuple de l'homo et
qui chez nous montrera les chevaux de
parce que il il est en CARG depuis les
années 60 et il fait un travail profond
sur la nature camargaise et sur les
chevaux de camarg et cette exposition
sera exceptionnellement à la
sous-préfecture de Rambouillet dont les
jardins seront ouverts au public le
weekend du 2 au 4 octobre alors en plus
de ces expositions le public pourra
participer également à différentes
activités des conférences des animations
des stages même oui c'est exact alors
l'ensemble des activités ou la majorité
des activités sont gratuites surtout C
c'est la destination des jeunes on a des
stages photos d'initiation pour les
jeunes par exemple ou de découverte de
la nature de sorties avec le Parc
Naturel Régional de Chevreuse de la
veille Chevreuse mais on a également
quelques stages photographiques plus
orientés macrophotographie par exemple
plus orienté brame du SER qui sont
payantes et qui se trouvent sur le site
internet du festive photo de la de la
forêt d'embouillé alors claud chose
votre collectif participe également au
festif photo comment avez-vous travaillé
pour votre exposition alors euh disons
que le les les Photo Club de l'Union
Régionale du sudouest Île-de-France si
vous voulez participe effectivement à
festif photo en collaboration avec mon
voisin si vous voulez et on a essayé de
recueillir les meilleures photos de
duur1 parce que nous avons quand même
quelques bons photographes animaliers
puisque nous avons reçu aussi keriaakos
CASIRA si vous voulez cette année dans
le cours de d'une d'une présentation de
son travail et nous avons programmer
d'ailleurs une masterclass aussi
photographique avec lui si vous voulez
donc qui se déroulera le 12 décembre on
a essayé de recueillir les meilleures
photos de l'IRE et puis aussi de l'Union
Régionale je veux dire et des unions
régionales adjacentes de façon à
présenter à l'intérieur du chalet de du
parc animalier de rambouiller donc les
meilleures photos de ces gens de ces
gens-là en grand format puisque c'est la
tendance que l'on dans lequelle on court
aujourd'hui et aussi cette exposition je
crois qu'on peut annoncer dè dès
aujourd'hui qu'elle se prolongera au
centre de 50 ans au centre commercial de
50 ans en Yveline si vous voulez tout de
suite après euh le 12 et 15 novembre si
mir sont exacts tout à fait alors c urcs
Claut chose est-ce que vous pourriez
nous en dire un mot peut-être pour qu'on
comprenne vraiment alors cette union
régionale du Sud-Ouest île-de- France
euh je dirais que représente la
Fédération Photographique de France dont
le siège est comment s'appelle sa
valallis à Paris euh si vous voulez sur
la région donc du Sud-Ouest et le France
c'estàdire que nous partons de
Montparnasse et puis on passe par une
partie des des départements des haut
scèes en fait la diffusion de TV FIF 78
voilà c'est un peu cette zone puisque
nous allons jusqu'à la queue les
ivelines et aussi rambouillé euh nous
regroupons 700 700 plus de 700
photographes et 23 photoc clubs si vous
voulez donc et on a participé à on
participe à beaucoup d'exposition dans
la région puisque nous avons c'est nous
qui avions invité RAA si vous voulez à
le 18 avril à 550 ieline qui a rencontré
un un Fran succès très belle
manifestation à laquelle vous avez fait
un ex en reportage je dois dire et donc
on a on a participé à si vous voulez ça
a été un très grand succès euh alors
vous êtes à renvoyé vous êtes également
à Montini le Bretonneux votre collectif
3 par 3 expose au conservatoire des
artsit pour une une exposition qui
s'appelle le beau et le surprenant
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire un
mot alors je peux vous en dire un mot
puisque euh souvenez-vous donc l'année
derrière je crois c'est en 2014 on avait
exposé aussi un collec il y avait
le l'état esprit des lieux une
exposition qui s'appelait esprit des
lieux et Michel logier donc maire de
Montin le Bretonneux je je m'arrêterai
sur ces titres nous avait demandé de
faire des photos sur le beau et le
surprenant à montigi donc ce sont des
gens qui font partie de photoc club mais
nous avons travaillé indépendamment nous
avons travaillé sur un regard sur
Montini de Bretonneux donc vous avez
espace vous avez mosaïque de de mosaïque
d'architecture vous avez périphérie vous
avez impression il y a les IGN montains
il y a diverses choses qui ont été
faites et par ce regard et je dois dire
par les regards de ces neuf personnes
sur le comment vous dire sur montinil
Bretonneux et je crois que cette exp
cette exposition qui dure jusqu'au 2
octobre rencontre un vif succès auprès
des gens parce que moi JEE je je viens
régulièrement et il y a pas mal de monde
qui viennent visiter cette exposition
donc c'est neuf approches différentes et
novatrices pour mettre en exerg la
beauté l'originalité de mon c'est ça
c'est ét c'est ça qui a été fait si vous
voulez c'est dans cet esprit là que ça a
été fait et c'est c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être des des choses qui sont
peut-être inhabituel que les gens n'ont
pas l'habitude de voir mais aujourd'hui
il faut savoir que la photo est évolue
dans ce qu'on appelle la photo dite
contemporaine où vous avez des des
regards qui sont un peu plus comment
vous dire particuliers donc où on va
mettre l'accent sur des points de détail
si vous voulez d'un de de d'une ville et
c'est ce que nous avons fait à travers
ce ce cette cette exposition alors
Jean-Philippe gibau est-ce que vous êtes
allé voir cette exposition oui oui oui
je voudrais rebondir sur ce que tu as
dit parce que j'ai pas complètement
répond à votre question tout à l'heure
parce que le parrain du festive photo
2015 c'est effectivement casiras
kirayakos
ou le monsieur qui a fait la conférence
à Montini et donc nous sommes très
contents de l'avoir comme parrain parce
que c'est un photographe qui a une
sensibilité tout à fait spéciale vous
avez pu le constater avec des Noirs et
Blancs profonds et tout à fait originaux
et c'est cette approche que vous allez
chercher à à mettre en avant lors du
Festif photo alors nous lors du Festif
photo notre approche c'est exposer pour
protégé c'est c'est notre crédau quoi
donc il y a beaucoup d'associations qui
qui travaillent à la protection de la
nature bon et qui sont très militants
nous notre approche à nous c'est de
montrer du beau pour espérer que les
gens détruisent un petit peu moins ce
qui ce qu'ils aiment et on a une
orientation très jeunesse donc on essaie
de de toucher les jeunes par exemple à
la salle patenaôre on fait des
expositions on a des associations qui va
qui viennent travailler avec nous pour
avoir euh un message et et et des sujets
très orienté vers vers les écoles et la
et la jeunesse alors la jeunesse
justement parlons-en Claude chose vous
venez également nous présenter un fest
un pardon non un festival un concours
photo qui est établi en partenariat avec
TVfil et votre ur1 voà d'accord oui bien
voilà c'est ça si vous voulez le
l'objectif que nous avons mis en place
avec vous d'ailleurs Sephora et puis
l'équipe de TVfil 78 que je remercie
dans ce caslà c'est de faire aujourd'hui
la photo est devenue un média qui est
extrêmement utilisé c'est aussi
peut-être de faire comprendre aux gens
par notre expérience parce que il y a
quand même des photographes chevronnés
dans notre union régionale de façon de
qu'on puisse expliquer aux gens comment
on peut mettre en valeur certaines
photos donc avec avec vous Sephora et
votre équipe on a monté un concours
photo qui sera ouvert à tous les les
résidents de de de de la zone de
réception de TVfil 78 un concours photo
dans qui s'appelle couleur d'automne qui
s'appelle couleur d'automne puisqueon y
arrive si vous voulez ça sera on n pas
voulu partir c'est des sujets très
complexes aujourd'hui et ce chacun aura
la possibilité de mettre donc ses photos
sur un site internet qui s'appelle
redaction@tvfil78.c al l'adresse
s'affiche à l'écran également donc voilà
et euh le public pourra voter sur ces
photos euh sur sur le facebook de TVF 78
donc un concours une photo par mois euh
ça sera alors c'est pas tout à fait une
photo par mois ça sera un thème par mois
et les gens pourront déposer autant de
photos qu'ils veulent un jury se réunira
composer des équipes de de de votre
rédaction des équipes des gens qui
participent dans nos dans nos tuners au
journal je on fera une sélection des des
meilleures photos et euh on
sélectionnera les cinq meilleurs et le
gagnant aura la possibilité de venir
présenter sur ce plateau sa photo et de
nous expliquer pourquoi il l'a fait et
comment il l'a faite et nous alors pour
redonne le thème
peut-être couleur d'automne donc
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui se rapporte à
aux couleur d'automne aux couleurs
d'automne je pense que c'est un sujet
très simple et la date limite pour
déposer vos photos c'est le 16 octobre
alors je sais que c'est peut-être un peu
tôt dans la saison pour avoir les belles
couleurs d'automne mais quand on regarde
la nature aujourd'hui si vous voulez ça
c'est un peu pour se relier ce que
disait mon ami sur festive photo si vous
voulez et bien on sent que l'automne
arrive il y a ne serait-ce que les des
couleurs du couchant toutes ces
choses-là si vous voulez il y a plein de
choses à faire merci Claude chose on
vous retrouvera régulièrement dans cette
émission pour nous présenter les
immanquables des photographes locaux et
nationaux et pour participer à ce
concours vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui
envoyer votre photo à l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran messieurs merci
rendez-vous pour le festif photo à
rambouillé qui démarre le 2 octobre
jusqu'au 4 et tout suite et et tout de
suite une exposition picturale qui se
déroule à la maison Félix de Montini le
Bretonneux nous allons nous initier à
l'arabstra lyrique image de William
l adonné à la peinture figurative depuis
10 ans Christophe Baudin se révèle
aujourd'hui dans l'art abstrait lyrique
exposition proposé à la maison Félix de
Montini le Bretonneux jusqu'au 27
septembre d'étoiles pluriell monochrome
ou très coloré éteré ou très graphique
pour réaliser ces toiles différents
outils peuvent être utilisés brosse
couteau éponge ou peigne mais la plupart
en ce point commun l'action painting
ensuite le tableau va être terminé avec
des projections et et je recherche
toujours ce mouvement libre donc d'où
d'où cette appellation de de action
painting on essaie de retrouver un
mouvement et on se on se libère on jette
la peinture carrément donc ça peut créer
des accidents il faut savoir aprivois
ces accidents les conserver et en tirer
une meilleure partie il suffit de diluer
la peinture avoir quelque chose de très
fluide et dans un petit gobelet pardemp
vous projetez comme ça et on a vraiment
une sorte d'explosion sur la
[Musique]
toile Christophe Baudin se reconnaît du
mouvement artistique appelé l'art
abstrait lyrique initié par George
Mathieu où l'art abstrait se définit par
l'absence de dessin pour laisser le
spectateur entièrement libre de son
interprétation c'est à se demander
comment peut nître l'inspiration je fais
attention vraiment au moment à des
moments cruciaux dans dans la journée
qui sont le moment d'éveil et le moment
d'enormissement et ce sont des moments
clés qui permettent de lancer une idée
et parfois lorsque je veux peindre je
vais simplement faire une sieste je
lance cette idée et quand je me réveille
je suis prêt et souvent la toile arrive
et pour l'anecdote l'illustre peintre du
surréalisme d procédé de la la même
façon pour puiser son inspiration avant
de
[Musique]
peindre musique de nouveaux invités à
présent pour nous présenter une très
belle initiative artistique Mireille
Frésil responsable de la communication
pour
SNL solidarité nouvelle pour le logement
et Jean-Claude freenau responsable de
solidarité nouvelle pour le logement
pour le groupe local implanté sur
SaintQuentin el
bonjour Alors Mireille Frésil
Jean-Claude Fréau pourriez-vous nous
nous présenter votre association disons
que c'est Jean-Claude qui va présenter
l'association
oui SNL solidarité nouvelle pour le
logement et une
association qui achèteent des logements
pour loger des des gens en très grandes
difficultés ce sont des des familles la
plupart du temps ou des des personnes
seules qui ne pe pas qui ne peuvent pas
avoir de de HLM
donc nous les logons dans des dans des
logements avec des loyers qui sont
extrêmement bas parce qu'habiter est une
nécessité votre association existe
depuis une vingtaine d'années absolument
euh pour accompagner ces personnes en
difficulté comment est-ce que vous
procédez comment les gens viennent à
vous alors les gens viennent à nous
avec au niveau de la préfecture
c'està-dire c'est la préfecture qui n
qui choisit euh à travers une commission
les les locataires qui les désignent et
nous demandent donc de louer des de leur
louer des logements et alors comment
vous fonctionnez pour récolter des fonds
parce qu'une
association pas voilà pour récolter des
fonds alors on a d'abord des subventions
des subventions de l'État de la
Région de de nos communes de de
l'agglomération et nous avons aussi
des subventions des fondations relation
à des pierres par
exemple nous nous avons aussi des prêts
en fait et puis il nous reste nous
groupe local 25 % du prix à recueillir
pour pouvoir acheter ses logements alors
justement Mireille je crois que vous
avez une belle initiative oui et vous
avez cherché à récolter des fois un peu
différemment cette fois-ci ou oui il y a
plusieurs manières de récolter des fonds
et entre autres il y a bien sûr il y a
la manière de de faire des des
manifestations publies grand public et
comme j'ai un ami un une cousine qui a
un fils qui a créé les bratches je me
suis adressé à eux pour leur dire s'ils
accepteraient de nous offrir un concert
et c'est sans aucune réticence qu'ils
ont dit oui ça a été extraordinaire
parce que vraiment j'ai trouvé ça
formidable alors justement avant d'en
parler pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
le groupe bratch c'est ça le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
batć
[Musique]
alors le group bratch c'est un folklore
imaginaire un savant mélange jazz
manouche russe roumain le group bratch
c'est 43 ans d'existence 15 albums plus
de 2000 concerts de par le monde et ce
concert sera l'un des ultimes avant leur
séparation ils vont se séparer à la fin
de l'année le 31 décembre 31 décembre
alors vous n disiez mire donc que vous
aviez fait appel à eux oui ils ont
répondu favorablement très bien très
très bien sans aucune rétisence
donc nous on a pris en charge toute la
communication sur le secteur on a été
aidé vraiment beaucoup par les instances
locales et politique parce que la salle
du Manet nous est louée gracieusement
bien qu'on paye quand même la les frais
mais bon alors vous vous espérez
récolter combien de fonds alors on sait
pas du tout c'est pour ça qu'on vient
chez vous parce qu'il faut absolument
que vous nous fassiez une pub
extraordinaire mais vous avez des une
attente un rêve peut-être oui on a un
rêve on a un rêve qui au moins 500
personnes dans la salle 500 personnes
oui au moins donc je rappelle que les
bénéfices de ce concert seront reversés
à l'association Solidarité nouvelle pour
le logement au profit des personnes en
grande difficulté pour se loger bratch
l'un de ses derniers concerts donc le 27
septembre à 17h30 à la Grange du Manet à
Montini le Bretonneux Mireille Frésil
Jean-Claude fréud merci d'être venu pour
nous présenter cette belle initiative
voilà on passe on passe maintenant à
notre rendez-vous régulier la sélection
[Musique]
littéraire vous invite à découvrir un
nouveau roman nouvel essai cette semaine
c'est la 9e fonction du langage de
Laurent Binet laurent Binet qui est
originaire des
ivelines bonjour Aujourd'hui je vais
vous présenter laurent Binet avec la 7e
fonction du langage qui est son dernier
roman par rue chez Grasset donc le
préambule du livre c'est Roland Bart qui
traverse la rue devant le collège de
France et qui se fait écraser par une
camionnette de blanchissage et là en
fait il tenait dans ses mains un
manuscrit sur lequel il travaillait
depuis un long moment qui est un
manuscrit qui permet de décrypter en
fait les les fonctions du langage et
cette fonction là permet en fait de de
de faire un peu ce qu'on veut avec les
foules donc de manipuler les foules et
de les emmener là où on veut et donc ce
manuscrit lorsqu'il se fait écraser il
se fait voler et donc tout le livre
commence en fait au départ sur cette
enquête là où pourquoi on a tué Roland
Bart et qui veut ce manuscrit qui est
tellement secret donc pour mener cette
enquête on va mettre un commissaire
boujadice totalement hermétique à toute
cette
vie toute cette vie étudiante et
culturelle de des années 70 et pour
l'accompagner on va mettre un petit un
petit jeune prof de fac qui va
l'accompagner qui va décrypter justement
tous les code de cette société qui est
pour lui totalement secrète quoi ce
commissaire va donc croiser toute la
société
euh culturel et intellectuel des années
70 donc il va croiser derida il va
croiser BHL dans ses jeunes années il va
croiser Solers il va croiser Lacan il va
croiser John Borg aussi il va croiser
mitteran voilà il va croiser tout ce
monde là toute cette vie intellectuelle
là des années 70 et 80 c'est vraiment
très drôle et très bien écrit le point
aussi important du bouquin c'est que il
y a un moment il va tomber sur une
société secrète un peu à la Fight Club
dont hberto et le
[Musique]
héros et je vous propose maintenant un
tout nouveau rendez-vous avec mareline
pou du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa de
saint-cirilécole qui va venir nous
présenter une fois par mois les
immanquables de la programmation jeune
public au cinéma mareline pou bonjour
bonjour Alors je crois que vous avez
trois événements à nous présenter et
nous commençons tout de suite avec une
programmation autour des petite
casserole alors oui le le programme
petite casserole c'est un programme de
film d'animation donc si cours age
d'animation euh on le conseille à partir
de 4 ans donc c'est un programme de six
films avec des techniques d'animation
très variées autour d'une thématique
commune qui est la les singularités la
différence voilà donc sur le la la
question de de pouvoir s'accepter
soi-même et sur ce programme alors on
fait un événement le 30 septembre donc
mercredi prochain à 14h un Siné goûé
animé avec un petit atelier créatif
alors il y a notamment dans le programme
une adaptation d'un livre jeunesse qui
s'appelle donc la petite casserole
d'Anatole et dans dans ce film Anatole
doit toujours traîner avec lui sa petite
casserole et voilà faire finir par faire
avec alors on va justement tout de suite
regarder un extrait de ces petites
[Musique]
casserole Anatole traîne toujours
derrière lui sa petite casserole elle
lui est tombée dessus un jour on ne sait
pas très bien
pourquoi en plus sa petite casserole lu
complique la
vie Anatole aimerait bien se débarrasser
de sa petite casserole mais c'est
impossible la petite casserole est là et
on ne peut rien y
faire et tout de suite un nouvel
événement programmé autour de Miss
okousa alors Miss okousa c'est un manga
donc un animé japonais pardon du
réalisateur Kishi ara qui avait
notamment signé le très beau dessin
animé colorful et on refait à nouveau
une soirée animation parce que ça a
pas mal de de succès en général donc
avec boruto en premier et Miss okousai
en 2e alors le le film Miss okousaï
c'est le le portrait d'une femme libre
la la fille du célèbre peintre okousaï
donc on on connaît le peintre auokousail
notamment peintre de de la célèbre
restante la la la grande vague et on
connait moins sa fille qui a pourtant
travaillé à ses côtés toute sa vie et
qui était aussi une très grande artiste
voilà c'est le portrait d'une d'une
femme libre et indépendante alors un
portrait à ne pas manquer justement pour
vous donner envie tout de suite un
[Musique]
extrait
et on continue avec Mar animatrice jeune
public au cinéma les yeux d'El qui nous
propose une fois par mois la
programmation alors Miss l'événement se
déroulera alors le 17 octobre de 20h à
minuitès avec des lots à gagner des
petits ancas et cetera et votre 3è
rendez-vous le 3è rendez-vous c'est avec
Phantom boy voilà donc le 3è coup de
cœur du mois de d'octobre et 3è ciné
goûté animé ça va être avec Phantom boy
alors là l'âge conseillé c'est plutôt 7
8 ans c'est un film d'animation un
policier fantastique avec un personnage
de super-héros euh donc déjà ça c'est en
soit assez original et c'est donc
l'histoire de donc ça se passe à New
York un personnage défiguré un gangster
va menacer de de détruire la ville et va
blesser un inspecteur Alex alors on
regarde tout de suite un
extrait si points de suure sacré d'un
chien un roquet avec la gueule d'un
requin dépêche-toi Léo on a besoin de
ton fantôme maintenant la ferme c'est
pas le moment paniquer je vous préviens
mon ami je vais manquer de
[Musique]
patience je m'appelle Léo j'ai 11 ans et
j'ai un secret je suis un
[Musique]
héros merci Marieline pou pour tous vos
événements on vous retrouvera le mois
prochain euh pour la programmation jeune
public au cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa de
sensir l'école et avant de nous quitter
quelques idées sorties pour ce weekend
depuis 2013 dans le cadre de l'opération
nationale monument en musique le Centre
des monuments nationaux invite dans son
réseau les musiciens de l'Orchestre de
Paris pour des rendez-vous uniques alors
rendez-vous au château de maison lafide
samedi 26 septembre à 20h30 et à la
ville à Savoie de poissie dimanche 27
septembre à 17h30 et enfin ne manquez
pas le concert d'électro de luxe pour un
cocktail survitaminé de jazz funk souou
et Grove à la batterie de Guy encour ce
soir vendredi 25 septembre à
20h30 le 78 weekend est terminé merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte en musique
avec un extrait du groupe électro de
luxe que nous retrouverons en interview
dans notre prochain kiosque mercredi
très bonne semaine à
[Musique]
tous
SH your and twi With
[Musique]
Me
twi
[Musique]
Nina
no